well we turn now to another interesting
happy story an important conversation
about the challenges that women face in
the workplace deb lue knows firsthand
she rose through the ranks of the
male-dominated tech industry to become a
vice president at facebook where she
created the site's marketplace future
lou is now ceo of ancestry the site that
helps people track their family history
her new book is take back your power 10
new rules for women at work in it she
draws upon her own experience to help
women thrive in their careers deb liu
welcome thank you so much for inviting
me yes absolutely so in your book you
talk about taking back your power but
you start off talking about how you were
giving it away and how often times
that's the case explain well you know so
many times when you're in the workplace
you're giving away your power in these
small ways like an example is when you
go into a room and you don't say
anything you go to a meeting my friend
carol izzazaki calls us the
unintentional ridiculous strategy you
don't go into a room and think at this
meeting i'm going to add no value or in
this meeting i'm not going to say
anything i'm going to sit in the back
and just listen but you do that how many
times you leave a room and you've done
that and so you know one of the things
about taking back your power is really
kind of saying what are let's be
intentional what do i want to do here
and other people are taking about taking
your power also interrupting you and
when you don't say anything you're
letting them do that so it starts with
the little things acknowledging that
that maybe we do that sometimes
and then making a decision to speak up
yes it is a choice each time you're in a
room each time you're in a conversation
you're making choices and those choices
really matter to how people perceive you
especially in a workplace where you're
not the majority so outside of speaking
up is there one particular thing you
think women should be doing to take back
their power i think the biggest thing is
learning to ask you know tell the story
of several women who are super powerful
but they were passed over for positions
because they didn't ask they didn't say
hey can i be your successor you know one
woman maybe tom she she actually trained
four of her bosses reporting to willie
brown before she actually said hey maybe
i could take the job and billy brown
said to her i thought you'd never ask
and the thing was she didn't raise her
hand no
now you write that what happens at home
impacts your success
as much sometimes more than what happens
at work um you are a mother so you know
what it's like to balance both what is
the key to
thriving
at home and at work i mean the biggest
thing is you know cheryl has the quote
the most important career decision you
make is who you choose to marry and that
is absolutely true because your partner
matters so much to the day-to-day of
your life you know whether you're the
household manager whether you're taking
care of the kids in their summer camps
you know a full partnership is the most
important thing you know can you
negotiate a full partnership can you
actually have somebody who's standing
side by side with you building your
careers together or are you kind of
taking on the full load and actually
having to take on all the household work
what about for single parents i think
for single parents it's hard to
negotiate because now everything is on
you so one thing is looking for a
workplace looking for a manager that's
supportive looking for flexibility
because that's going to make the big
difference for you
you talk about i mean let's
think about young children and the
messages that they're exposed to when
they're very very young we've all seen
those onesies right the onesies will say
pretty like mommy smart like daddy so
the messaging that we see in films uh
with male action stars video games
usually males at the center of those
games um how does this impact women in
their careers much later on well you
know there's studies that show that when
you ask little boys and girls you know
who's someone smart they draw someone
just like them and then by the time
they're in elementary school they're six
seven eight as they get older they
actually start skewing towards males
because they're you know they're
acculturated to think okay someone who's
smarter than me someone who's a leader
what does a leader look like and i think
that that goes on in your career what
does what does if i ask you what does a
ceo look like in america i think you
would imagine one thing and it wouldn't
be someone like me and that's you know
something which i grew up with it never
occurred to me that i would ever reach
this place because that's not what i was
taught and i think those lessons kind of
build on themselves slowly and quietly
over many many years can i ask you a
question about ancestry.com uh because
it's a fascinating company i'm usually
interested in genealogy and ancestry and
i'm curious what kind of efforts you're
making in gathering data to help people
who are not of european descent so
people from the caribbean people from
asia latin america uh the middle east
what kind of databases you're putting
into ancestry to help them figure out
who they are well since i've been ceo
which is about 18 months we've been
really focusing on an effort called
ancestry for all and it's really how do
we make ancestry more accessible we have
incredible records from western european
countries but you know one thing we've
lacked is is more records from other
countries as well and so that's one of
our big initiatives over the next
several years is to gather records and
make it more accessible to everyone on
our platform
deborah liu thank you so much for
joining us thank you for the invitation
take back your power goes on sale next
tuesday